Much like game of thrones before it,
Hbo Westworld is an elaborate at big
puzzle box of a production that serves
in the end as an excuse to explore
something much smaller and much more
important character.
This is why despite the sweeping vistas
what holds everything else up or the
conversations,
how they're written and how they're
acted,
and today I want to take a look at one
conversation featuring the Great Anthony
Hopkins.
Specifically,
I want to examine how hopkins acts the
scene,
how he elevates every line of dialogue
to a hypnotically interesting level.
You'll imagine I've gone mad.
You lost my way.
Simply concerned about the extent of the
changes you're making.
You want to protect the legacy.
My legacy.
Okay.
The background of the scene is that
Teresa Colon and operations manager of
the westworld theme park is trying to
stop or at least stall the creation of
Robert for Anthony Hopkins,
new storyline for the guests.
The storyline that is generally wreaking
chaos on things to the point of worrying
the parks financier's.
It's clear that Theresa feels that
Ford's undertaking is just too risky,
but instead of forthrightly telling him
so she puts things in euphemistic terms,
you want to protect your legacy
legacy.
Okay,
that pause is fully seven seconds long
and it is amazing after reacting in
disbelief at such a shameless euphemism,
hopkins in silence cycles through a few
emotions first disbelief than a
consideration of the words for a split
second at their face value.
Maybe he should safeguard his legacy.
Maybe he shouldn't be so ambitious at
his age.
Then a smile and this scene will feature
several shades of smile.
This one is kind as kind as can be in
the face of what he considers to be an
attack.
One that insults his intelligence as he
looks down and chuckles.
The smile seems to acquire some
suppressed anger.
You can only bear to look at her in
quick glances as he composes himself.
Then he fires back and antagonistic
remark.
You're done.
Like this space that amounts to.
I've seen many of you come and go over
the years and I can tell the ones who
enjoy the time here,
the ones who don't.
What's impressive here is how hopkins
breaks down the dialogue as written in
interviews.
Hopkins has described how he reads
scripts 200 times or so to the point
where the dialogue is lodged in his
brain that he steps away.
Let's sit,
gestate in his mind,
and when he arrives on set,
he relaxes himself and let the punk days
where you by having such a command over
the words,
hopkins is able to modulate the tempo of
their delivery to get the most out of
it.
This sentence,
for example,
is spread through.
I've seen many of you come and go over
the years and as as the first part of
the next sentence,
until a pause,
after who drawing out the word enjoy,
which falls right back into a speedy
delivery,
almost slipping over the words until the
final two,
which coupled with icontact,
slowed down to function.
As an accusation.
I've seen many of you come and go over
the years and I can tell the ones who
enjoy the time on pseudo.
I admire it,
the audacity of it,
a small interjection,
but see how he opens up like a flower
from the hunched position,
how he releases a little tension to
receive the compliment.
Great touch.
I came there once as a child with my
parents.
I think we even sat at this table when I
started working here.
I realized this place wasn't something I
would enjoy and then we get a second
interjection.
When his suspicions are confirmed,
followed by hunching again and at the
fleeted neck.
Then from this position,
Hopkins launches into his key speech.
In the beginning,
I imagined things would be perfectly
balanced.
Even the beds with my partner Arnold,
to that effect,
they made 100 hopeful storylines.
Of course,
almost no one took us up on the last.
The bad.
Arnold always held a somewhat dim view
of people.
He preferred the hosts.
They begged me not to let you people in
the money,
man,
tell us,
okay,
we're about to learn that this whole
meeting is a threat setup by Hopkins and
to signal that Hopkins incrementally
dials up the menace across three terms
that specify who he threatening you
people,
money,
men delos,
listen to it again.
They begged me not to let you people in
the money,
men Delis,
but I told him,
if you find that you didn't understand
what you are paying for,
it's not a business venture.
Now seem an entire world designed every
inch of it,
every blade of grass in here.
We have a God's Mandy August.
Watching this,
the first time it was here that it
struck me how crucial Ford's personality
is to the functioning of the series.
I mean,
westworld is in many ways a ridiculous
idea both as a theme park and as a TV
show to work.
The conceit had to be mapped,
reflected,
justified in the complex desires and
ambitions of its creators.
The writers have achieved that in Fort,
but it's hopkins who really brings these
things to light and how did that work?
For sadly,
he lost his perspective.
He went mad.
I haven't,
as you well know,
I've always seen things very clearly the
threat now,
explicit hopkins colors the rest of the
scene with a sinister glean.
This is the table I sat with my parents.
They know everything about our guests.
Don't pay as we know everything about
our employees.
From here on out,
he presses his advantage not with force,
but with comfort,
with a smile,
no longer needing to convince Teresa of
his dominance,
hopkins dances and different attitudes
for a couple of seconds before falling
back into that smile like right here
where he's.
Matter of fact,
we know everything about our guests
don't pay as we know everything about
our employees or here where he's
concerned,
I do hope he will be careful with a nod
or here where he's genuinely caring as
his eyes wander off for a moment too.
It has a sensitive disposition.
The producers of the show are smart to
keep the camera fixed on Hopkins face.
His ability learned across many decades
to convey such a web of feeling and
suggest such a universe of feeling
within about a character we know little
about expands.
The entire shows range and strengthens
it's persuasive power as a piece of art.
That's what a great actor can do.
You can give words and images or a short
scene like this of volcanic energy with
the quiet look and Anthony Hopkins hands
in his eyes.
Westworld isn't just a reflection of its
creators personality.
It's a self portrait.
You can tell the board that I needed to
be completed on time and it won't be a
retrospective as I'm sure you have so
sentimental.
How.
Hey everybody,
there is a new nerd writer video every
Wednesday,
so if you click right there,
you'll subscribe to this channel and get
all the videos.
Sorry,
I've been so irregular with my posting
recently.
I've been in Italy.
It's been crazy,
but also have been writing a couple of
speeches for the Singapore Writers
Festival,
which I'll be at in a couple of weeks.
Um,
and so that's been taking a lot of my
time.
I have to shout out a channel that I
really love called wisecrack.
They do video essays like me,
eight,
the philosophy,
earthlink,
cinema,
stuff like that.
They just did something on bojack
horseman,
which is a show I love and the video is
great too,
so I'll link that below.
Check that out.
Thanks guys for watching.
I'll see everybody next Wednesday.
Hopefully.